well let's roll okay efore okay if I'm
fearful of the grünfeld I'll play e4 I
almost mouse slipped I don't want to
meet the grin felt I I like this setup
instead so black isn't gonna be playing
d5 being cut out King side fiend keto
pointing at d4 indirectly
I'm gonna want to lend support to d4
anticipating I neither see v e5 break
let's go
Bishop out
what else Queen d2 Queen d2 92 I want to
be in a spot if this pawn is challenged
this is what I was gonna get out I want
to be in a spot to be able to recapture
on d4 with my knight also keep in mind
that if you're playing the white side
and you're excited about the following
Queen d2 Bishop h6 don't do it because
you fit it fails tactically tonight take
c4 file by Queen h4 check notice the
Queen from h4 hits the king and the h6
square I could play Queen d2 right now
but is d5 gonna be played Queen d2 d5 I
take this pawn and then chop here later
I think that that'll be okay so there's
no need in other words to release the
tension in the center I want to reserve
options here I want to be able to play
d5 or maybe capture on e5 it's looking
more like I'll either maintain the
tension or play d5 I think it benefits
black if I just take on e5 so now what
do I do
I was saying I want to keep a piece
around to recapture on this square
alright I want to keep my knight around
to recapture on d4 but I also want to
get my light square Bishop out and I
don't know if I want to play g3 Bishop
g2 because that does weaken the f3
square
g3
I think after takes takes Knight here
I'm having to play here something to
watch both c4 and f3 and then there's
Bishop h3 stuff so I don't think being
Catalan the bishop is a good idea I
don't know about queenside castling
either I think I want to move my knight
but I think now that this pawn is
supported maybe something like d5 is
more of a possibility opening up the
position at
where I'm still lagging and development
so that was a mouthful that right there
that was just rattling off so after all
that I think it's important maybe the
the most concise way to say it is I am
behind in development so I want to make
a move right now that's going to close
the position up so that it can buy me
some time to complete my development
okay also how would you recapture an
night ponpon of these two I'm definitely
thinking about this one towards the
center let's have a good reason not to
if I go like this then this move is
available
this move is available as well and what
else well that's enough I I just don't
want this pond to have the possibility
to move I also don't want to take with
my night because a I have a space
advantage and be if my night captures
and this night recaptures this pond is
already in a position to play f5 and
getting back to what I was saying
previously I don't want the position to
open up to so quickly here so now what
where'd I want to go Kings cider my
knight needs to make a decision clean
side maybe getting to the c6 square C 1
B 3 a 5 C 6 that seemed far-fetched
maybe it is or G 3 bishop here and King
site Castle Knight g3 would stop a
knight move to h5
they hear it's gonna have to move again
I think I like this I don't want to
allow this night h5 move
so now what let's see
I don't know what the candidate moves
should be for black for me I'm gonna be
going to either d3 or e2 with my light
squared Bishop and I'm pretty sure
kingside Castle one thing I have to be
concerned about is H 5 H 4 that could be
slightly annoying because my knight
really doesn't have a great retreat
square I'm gonna do this just in case
this pawn gets the idea to kick my
knight away that could jump here I don't
want to give up my dark Suresh up he's
my better Bishop should I be concerned
about Knight takes bishop you know what
I'm gonna hang on to him even those are
he's a bad guy I'm still looking to
maintain pieces on the board and I would
like to play b4 and that's got to be
very uncomfortable for black so since I
do want to play b4 I'm not gonna Castle
queenside so I finally am able to make
up my mind here let's play b4 I'm
assuming knight here is best if it plays
here the knight is practically dead -
the game also I want to make sure I get
this in before a5 is played also before
I Castle this right here is a move that
my opponent can not prevent me from
doing but I want to get this move in
first yes because this Knight is looking
to maybe play to b6 or in other words b5
Knight b6 + c4 this is a sensitive point
in my position and I could already say
that as a result of the b4 mode so I'm
doing a 4 so that after b5 I could play
a 5 and then there's no way to make use
of the beast 6 square anymore with
either the knight or bishop trying to
gain more space I'm trying to control
more squares on the Queen side of the
board so that the maneuvering about
more difficult for black so now that I'm
have this in I'm ready to castle it's
been a been a bit
this is move 16 but I think I've
obtained an advantage so now the final
phase is to try and make use of this
advantage my bishop wants to get back
here just sidestep tonight capture
that's why Elam it's the only reason I
came back to c2 is to avoid a knife for
Bishop exchange now I want to put
pressure on this pawn and even follow up
with this so now my Bishop could play
here I'm going to not play here because
I want to make use of this square now
with my bishop before the rook maybe
even thinks about playing here I want to
trade LightScribe bishops let's come
over here because I might want to take
with my pawn and then get this sort of
thing going I would love to get a knight
here or even me no no no no no no I
should have played about my Bishop I'm
gonna do that now Bishop takes pawn
tanks I just want my knight to play
right here although I'm dropping stuff
where am i no now I'm getting them some
material here pin or excuse me a skewer
so now okay
okay let's do this there's no Queen tags
tricky Forks capture like this the
knight is boxed out and it's a connected
passed pawn and now one pig on the
seventh looking for another Queen hear
Queen here and that's close to game set
match in fact there's no stopping Queen
here I'm on the bishop twice there's a
no way to defend the bishop be there ten
seconds for black okay that's the ball
game they're a good game let's go back
good game mr. ed bow go flip this board
and see if there's a thing or two or
three we could maybe take away
from this for either side um let's see
what move jumped out at me as being
maybe off I wonder this is kind of tough
isn't it I gave you a tough time I gave
you a tough time hang on to be honest
with you I think I've encountered this
same setup I think I've played the black
side of this and I struggled to find
something to do as well so what do you
do what do you do here hang on what's
something else we could be doing well
here's one thing if you really don't
like having to deal with this closed
structure you could consider maybe just
capturing and playing rook here knight
c6 to e5 just so you could pivot about
you could work on piece play having your
knight make use of e5 so you could go in
that direction just pointing out a way
to change the structure huh what else
kind of gets tough definitely gets tough
here maybe instead of okay well that
night that that pawn will seems like
it's pretty purposeful because if Knight
you know if the Knights allowed here
that's a problem isn't it it's probably
a problem I'm wondering if there's a way
that you could get in this Knight h5
before I play Knight g3 is there an
opportunity for you to do that how about
right now hmm how about right now
maybe Knight h5 right now if I'm playing
a move like g4 well then that's gonna
change the complexion of the game
castling kingside
probably not going to happen for white
you could look into maybe Knight h5
before I'm getting to this g3 square so
recognize the opportunity you have at
this particular point because as soon as
you play your knight here
you'll know d5 comes with the threat of
just winning upon takes Queen takes pawn
you take Irie capture and also since the
night is here and the queen is not
seeing d6 directly there is another
annoying thing with Knight b5 which you
did take into account with a 6 but at
this point now it's too late to make
this night maneuver and I don't know
that retreating the knight - let's say e
8 looking for f5 is really manageable
because I could develop to d3 and make
it still difficult for you to get that
advance in so maybe this was an
opportunity for you I cannot be certain
of this this is you know rough thoughts
here but I am seeing this is maybe a
possibility right here after Queen d2
look into the night move and then maybe
later the Knight to d7 move okay because
it's kind of tough I think I I gave I
gave you a problem maybe b5 is another
one to try and get in Knight b6 to c4
this turned out to backfire if you try
to maintain the Knights position with a
5 then I'd make use of this square I get
on this diagonal so it becomes very
difficult very very difficult here
there's very little space now for black
and I think it's uh it's it's no good
there's I think white is just better
here clearly better so look into that
night h5 move maybe okay
Knight h5 with the f5 move idea